to my beautiful wife the greatest gift
and I love being a parent with you so
multi-marie hi babe
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
just weeks after Nick Jonas and Priyanka
chopra's daughter malty made her big
debut at her dad's Walk of Fame ceremony
the actress shares a new rare look at
life with their little love bug on
Valentine's Day
Love Bug again pre-posted this photo
with her hubby and this sweet shot
holding malty near a lake she wrote in
the caption my forever Valentines I have
a lot of faith in who my husband is and
I know I have a lot of faith in the rock
that he is for our family Nick's getting
sentimental too sharing a
behind-the-scenes look at their romantic
date night simply writing a perfect
Valentine's Day With My Heart
[Music]
I don't know how this could get much
better the couple's life got a whole lot
better after they welcomed their
daughter last January I love kids I
always have loved kids Nick and free
kept Maltese little face a secret for
her first year only making some mostly
covered cameos on her parents feet
including this stunning shot posing with
Mama inside British folks February issue
how's fatherhood been in for you because
everybody says it's life-changing to you
it is certainly life-changing she's uh
she's amazing brings me a lot of Joy all
is good but for her daddy's big day the
Jonas Brothers Walk of Fame ceremony the
one-year-old made in her first public
appearance that's a special thing and
you know I think as as parents it's
everything has a new meaning and has
even more meaning and moments like this
especially well multi will one day see
her mom and dad share a special moment
on the big screen too when she's old
enough to watch priyanka's latest
rom-com love again I miss you so much
making the inside of
inside of me do you have a question for
me yes yes Mr do you really believe in
all these things you sing you obviously
know nothing about it what
aside from the music icon herself Celine
Dion appearing in the film Nick makes a
cameo as priyanka's blind date because
when the sun comes up maybe we just take
it a little slower and go
they're never gonna hold me down yeah
we're thinking their first date went a
lot smoother IRL how did you know that
your fiance was the one how did you know
uh it was kind of an instant thing new
once we locked in together that I had a
partner for life and a teammate so I can
walk to the good times and bad times
with and was that was the key yeah I'm
blushing now
[Music]